[Music]
we know a go-getter when we see one an
Abby Lee Miller never felt to rise to
the occasion we've seen her backside and
he's heard rumors about her good side
but issue really as mean as they say she
owes who knows the answer to that
question better than Abby's very own
students
city let's kick things off with his
Ziggler sisters who have both made it to
a point to cut Abby out of their lives
the Ziegler's cut all communication off
with Abby after leaving Dance Moms at
the end of season six
although Abby did help transform Maddie
into one of the most successful dancers
in America she also left a bitter taste
in her mouth turns out that years of
criticism extreme pressure and tough
love with her put an end to the millers
[ __ ] alliance the same can be said
about Chloe Luke Asia who's obviously
not interested in forgiving her former
dance coach who once made fun of her
medical condition according to Chloe
Abby has taught her a lot of life
lessons and turned her into a better
dancer but when it comes to her
personality she'd rather keep her
distance
oddly enough Kenzi Maddie and Chloe are
the ones who make it a point to ignore
Abby at all costs other dancers like
Kendall virtus still keep in contact
with Abby and she even considered her as
the strongest woman she knows despite
facing some legal issues in the past
Kendall and Abby have made amends
Jojo with the Bobo on the other hand has
never stopped showering Abby with
support and affection the see was invite
Abby to their Christmas party's special
events and birthday parties - Jojo even
visited Abby when she was in the
hospital and brought her loads of
presents obviously she thinks very
highly of her old dance teacher
Kalani also seems to be on the same page
as Jojo during an interview with Access
Hollywood Kalani stated that she learned
a lot from Abby and wishes heard the
best she also mentions that she doesn't
really keep in contact with Abby but
she's forever grateful for what she
taught her other dancers like Ileana
Walmsley and Maisy seis make it a point
to keep in touch with Abby Lee Miller
visited a B in the hospital and boasted
about how wonderful the experience was
the girls obviously have a lot of love
for their teacher and maisy would even
go as far as to label a BS or zero
Ileana loves how Abby holds her
accountable for everything and truly
believes that her teachings have turned
her into a better performer these girls
just love working with Abby it's old
news that the producers of Dance Moms
tweaked the footage to make everything
seem super dramatic
Abby's worst traits are showcased while
her soft side gets downplayed so it's
hard to put a finger on Abby's real
personality if Dance Moms had never
become a reality TV show it's possible
that Chloe Maddie and Kenzie
but since the show mainly focused on
Chloe and Maddie's on-screen rivalry we
can see why these girls want nothing to
do with the ALDC not only did Abby put a
lot of stress on Maddie but she spent
the rest of her time comparing Kenzie
and Chloe to her star pupil so obviously
the girls had way too much pressure on
them and they're holding on to all the
bad memories but while the og dancers
have a lot of bad things to say about
Abby
her new cast can't help but praise her
for her teaching methods according to
Brady there's no other coach like her
despite finding her heart and picky
she's confident that she knows what's
best so he's more than happy to take on
her criticism according to Presley feel
a little bit stressful because you feel
like you have to be perfect but she also
stated that it's a whole lot of fun to
Presley knows that Abby wants perfection
which isn't always an easy thing to
achieve the sweet and adorable Cameron
on the other hand has only nice things
to say about her dance coach he's flat
he thinks he's Flynn in her opinion Abby
is super fun because she teaches her
moves she's never done before and she
likes her for it
but when it comes to Liliana at the
dancer thing said it's easy for Abby to
come across his name somehow when she
says it
it just sounds me your laziness your
lack of musicality
however she believes that she's just
trying to give important feedback
despite her coming off as brood and mean
Lilly knows to brush off her tone while
taking her Corrections to heart a lot of
tough love coming for you suck it up kid
Abby is all about tough love but that's
what she loves about her Hannah also
finds Abby to be very strict but she
loves having her as a dance teacher she
tells me stuff like corrections that
I've never had before
in Hannah's opinions she's become a
better dancer thanks to Abby's
Corrections and criticism there's a huge
fan of Abby's she loves working with her
and sees her as a really good teacher
sure she can be blunt and honest and
tell you exactly what you don't want to
hear but in the end
Abby turns her students into the best
versions of themselves although her
methods can be a little harsh especially
since she works with children her
numbers speak for themselves is safe to
say that if you want to train with Abby
you better have thick skin because it's
her way or the highway still hearing her
students praise her and makes you wonder
if she's really as bad as she seems she
obviously loves her students and wants
them to succeed in life
so should Abby rethink her teaching
methods and be kinder to her students
or is her no-nonsense personality what
makes her the best in the industry sound
off in the comments section and that's a
wrap don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching see you next time
on the things
[Music]